[Music]
studying language is a privilege
when you analyze language in everyday
speech you realize that there is an
astonishing amount of wonder in the
system that we take for granted
linguists questioned the obvious which
is language
and got answers that forever change
mankind's understanding of language and
human nature
in this video you will see what
linguists know
that is not so evident to other people
so let's see what we've got
we all speak one language one of the
main discoveries of modern linguistics
is that
it made us aware that all the languages
we speak are similar in astonishing
respects
they manifest the same pattern follow
the same rules they are learned in the
exactly same way
and that all the differences are only
superficial so in a sense we all speak
the same language
this was captured by chomsky in an
excellent metaphor
titled language and mind in which he
says that if a martian scientist
somebody with a different kind of
intelligence were to study the world's
languages
he would conclude that they are all
dialects of a single language
embodying a universal grammar reflecting
a hard-wired genetically determined
linguistic module
inherent in the human brain a studies of
topologically different languages show
that
this is indeed the case i will mention
in passing one of probably the main
arguments
used to prove this take a child that was
born in china
and have him raised in saudi arabia and
hill grove speaking arabic
what does that say to you it says that a
human child is hardwired to learn any
languages
and that all human languages say
mandarin and arabic in this case
are fundamentally the same if they
weren't the task of child to learn any
language would be impossible
this has massive implications the
greatest of which
is that all the 7 000 human languages
have the same source and that every
language spoken today
evolved from the same great great great
grandmother tongue
another implication is that if a martian
would fly past our planet
he would hear japanese and ojibwe like
we hear british and american english
this is an interesting line of thought
if you want to read more about it
i got a good book you could read it's
called chomsky's universal grammar
an introduction part 2 language change
is natural people so often combat
language change and are feared by
it linguists know that natural language
change is not bad for a language
adopting long words from other languages
losing inflection
cases genders articles and formally
distinct sounds
this happens in all languages and is
nothing to worry about
for linguists it's an interesting
phenomenon worth analyzing
for some people it's proof for the
demise of language the end of civilized
culture and the beginning of the dying
of the proper language but languages
constantly change and this is certainly
not how languages die
too many people fear language change
many people think that if we don't
attempt to regulate the correct form of
speaking
from spelling to pronunciation to word
choice then we will all plunge into
anarchy or some sort of misfortune
it's sham language constantly evolves
and even those
political or cultural elites who claim
to use it correctly
fail to do so themselves and even those
who fancy themselves
as guardians of the correct way of
speaking can even agree on whether split
infinitives
are kosher societies arise and fall but
not because too many people started to
say ain't when they
should have said isn't part three
there are no bad grammars one of the
things you know when you start studying
languages is that you realize how stupid
is the claim that says there are bad
grammars
linguists know that all dialects even
those considered bad grammar
by many people are as fully formed and
rule-bound as any other language
someone who uses appalachian dialect or
african-american vernacular english
to use two united states examples is not
simply ignorant of grammatical roles
taught in school
or speaking sloppily they are following
a different set of roles which
are consistent within their own dialect
sometimes the linguistic complexity of
languages
associated with underprivileged
societies and that we call bad grammars
far exceeds that of modern and
privileged societies
william lapov in fact analyzed
african-american
vernacular english and showed us that it
is a beautiful language with a
sophisticated structure
and has many features that standard
english lacks
you can read more about this lava's own
book titled language in the inner city
studies in the black english vernacular
part 4
there are monolingual linguists
i don't know how to stress this further
being a linguist does not equal being a
polyglot
while it's true that linguists study all
languages this does not mean
that they engage in learning them they
only study them to test certain
hypotheses related to how languages work
linguists know that there are
monolingual linguists there are even
linguists who advise against learning
languages
seriously people should stop using
linguist and polyglot or language lover
synonymously
the surest way to annoy a linguist is to
ask so how many languages do you speak
part 5 language is fractal
languages know that you really can't
fully describe any human language
it seems to be impossible to produce
enough rules to fully describe
any natural language you always find
that there are wild expressions that
your rules forbid
and invalid expressions that your roles
permit that's what we mean when we say
all grammars leak of course you can
create new rules to cover those
exceptions
but teams have spent decades at this
without closing
all the holes despite creating tens of
thousands of roles
this is one reason linguists have
trouble taking grammar perspectivists
seriously we know that no description of
grammar small enough to fit in a single
volume can be anything more than a set
of guidelines
part 6 monoglots can become polyglots
linguists know that everybody who speaks
one language can learn others if they
want to
the mathematics behind linguistics for
example automata theory and chomsky's
hierarchy of languages
indicate that an astonishing amount of
intelligence is required to become a
monoglot
the more we study computational
linguistics the automata theory
the more we understand this the simplest
theoretical machine that could
accurately parse a human language and
map to meanings
would be incredibly complex surprisingly
the amount of complexity
one must add in order to parse a second
language is almost negligible
in other words there is no real
difference in the intelligence necessary
to become a monoglot or a polyglot
perceived differences in difficulty have
more to do with learning as an adult
versus as a child
during the critical period and with the
enjoyment of learning
and willingness to work i'm sure
linguists know so much more that can be
said in the video
language changed our perceptions about
language change the way we regard
minority languages
and most importantly linguists made us
aware that no language is inferior
join the bandwagon to recognize the
efforts of linguists
by subscribing to this channel and
sharing this video
thank you very much for watching this
video i'll see you soon